haití primer país independiente de
américa latina y actualmente también el
más pobre de la región 11 2 millones de
habitantes viven en este país arrasado
en los últimos años por un terremoto en
2010 y el huracán matthew en 2016 tras
ambos desastres el país recibió gran
cantidad de ayuda internacional que ha
estado rodeada de interrogantes la deuda
externa del país superaba el 36 por
ciento en 2020 y la supuesta ayuda
internacional ha hecho haití más
dependiente del exterior la pobreza
arrasa la población haitiana los sueños
de la revolución de esclavos que la
llevó a la independencia nunca se
cumplieron se calcula que más del 20 por
ciento de la población vive bajo el
umbral de la extrema pobreza en este
contexto la crisis derivada de la
pandemia de kobe 19 sólo ha empeorado la
situación hay una crisis humanitaria con
escasez de alimentos y haití es de los
pocos países del mundo que no ha
recibido ninguna dosis de la vacuna a
todo esto se le suma la crisis política
que estalló en 2015 hubo comicios en los
que ganó job en el mois el mandatario
asesinado pero no fue reconocido por la
autoridad electoral
de un año después allí comenzó la
controversia para moix en este momento
comenzaba su mandato para la oposición
un año antes
así moix defendía que su mandato
acabaría en 2022 cuando no se
presentaría a las elecciones el
parlamento está disuelto por decreto
desde enero de 2020 y la oposición ya no
reconocía la legitimidad de moix que
gobernaba ahora por decreto en febrero
de este año las calles estallaron en
protestas en esa fecha según la
oposición moix debería haber entregado
el poder desde entonces el gobierno de
moix detuvo a 20 opositores por supuesto
golpismo que más tarde fueron absueltos
por un tribunal móvil se había declarado
enemigo de la oligarquía que controla
los negocios claves como la banca o la
energía en un país que ha sufrido el
gran aumento del precio de los
combustibles ha grabado también por la
falta de envío de crudo desde venezuela
su otrora principal proveedor las bandas
siempre han también al país de violencia
y se calcula que controlan hasta el 60
por ciento del territorio sólo durante
este pasado junio ha muerto más de 150
personas y otras 200 han sido
secuestradas en el área metropolitana de
puerto príncipe
la capital que ha tenido más de 20
gobiernos en 35 años por el momento
nadie ha conseguido la estabilidad